こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
泣
バンッ！
う～う～う～ううううう
鼻をすする音
すいません
今まで
僕が
東京に行っていた時
そして
移動中
八っグ！！
今使っているデスクトップのパソコンを買う前まで
(鼻をすする音)
う～う～うううううう
わぁ～わぁ～わぁ～うぉ～うぉ～うぉ～
オ↑～オ↑～オ↑～
今まで、僕が
僕が、Youtubeをやってきてここまで来れたのは
間違えなく
バンッ！
このmacbook proのおかげです
鼻をすする音
んはッ
でも
今日で、お別れです
この子は
長い間
僕を助けてくれた
いつ買ったんだっけ
いつ買ったんだか分からないよぉ～～
よぉ～↑お～↓おおお
うわあああああああああああああ
お前いつ届いたんだよお～
ピ～ンポ~
は～い
本当にずっとお世話になりました
本格的に編集し始めたのはこのパソコン買ってからなので
あ！そうだ
いつ買ったか
なんか情報でないかな～？
2014年ですね
2014ってことは
2年間ぐらいかな～？
たぶん2年間ぐらいですね
2014年のモデルなんで
たぶん、2年間ぐらいずっと
このパソコンで
無駄にパソコンに負荷をあたえるような編集をしてもらって
本当にお世話になったと思っております
いや～、すごいよ
動画の編集ってすごい負荷がかかるんですよ
重くて
この子も限界まで頑張ってくれてたんですけど
本当の限界といいますか
中身も重くなったのとあるし
マウスでこう動かしてから5秒後ぐらいに動くとか
ちょっと動かしたらちょっとすぐ考え中マークで
20秒止まったり
そういうことが非常に多くなってきて
いろいろ中身消したり
クリーンとかしてみたんですけど
あんまり変わらなくて
もう
寿命かな？と思いまして
今この動画をもちまして
この
うううううう～うう
マックブックウウウウウウウ
このmacbook proとお別れします
ううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううううう
うううさよなら、本当にありがとう
本当にありがとうございます！
投げちゃダメ！！
僕をここまで作ってくれたパソコンといや～こいつなんで
彼の意志を引き継ぐ形で
今度からこのパソコンを使ってこうと思います！！
ビリビリビり～～～～～～
バンバンバンバンバンバン
箱が倒れる
うわあああああああああああああああああああ
箱を殴ったり蹴ったりする音
えへ
macbook proの新型でございます
これがなんかすごいてきな？
良いタイミングででたなと思ったので買ったんですけど
もう結構いろんなYoutuberさん使ってて
ちょっと出遅れたん出すけども
発売したとともに買って今届きました
なんで俺つまようじで開けてんだろ～？
ま、非常に悲しいですよ～
本当ずっとね、使ってきたパソコンは
いろんな思い出が入ってる
でもね、やっぱね
人間は
前に進まなきゃダメなんですよ
(ビニール袋の音)
うえっ
では開けていきましょう
うわぁ、macbookか～すげ～久しぶりだな
あれ？macの匂いがしないぞ！？
でました～こちらでございます
これ、こ、これのやつでしょ
あれ？
わぁ～でた！
わっ！
わぁ～
色がすごい
薄っ！！
薄いそして
薄いですな
はいそして、これが新型のmacbook proでございます
あとは、あれと、あれと、あれがついてます
これで、途中から遅くなったから
もうちょっとスペックをよくしようと思って
15インチ、これより1個大きいサイズを買った予定なんです
あ！？
15インチだよね？あってる、あってる
あ～やっぱでかいな～
サイズがやっぱり一回りぐらいちょっとこっちのほうが大きいですな
これでわかると思うんですけどかなり、薄くなっております
いや、そうでもねぇや
っていうわけで開けてみましょうか
誰だ、このいたずらした奴は！？
うお！？
はい！っというわけで今回すごいのはですね
ここですね
もう、動くんすよタッチしたら
うおい　　うおい
HAJIMEって打ったら勝手にここに変換がでてきます
ああ便利だな、
ここでも入力できんの？
顔じゃん！？
ほっこりのある
え！？便利だな～可愛いな～
こんな可愛いキーボードあります？？
タッチしたらそのまま貼り付けれるというやつでございます
うわぁなんかやべぇ
すっげぇストーカーみたいなやつになっちゃった
はい！っというわけで
新しいパソコンを買ったという話でございました
やっぱ移動してると
どうしてもね、ノートパソコンでの編集がメインになってくるんで
なるべくっいいやつを買いました
大切にしますう
はあああ
今までありがとうな
mac ブク男
君と動画を作れて、僕はたのしかったよ
何言ってんだよ、お前がいなかったら今の俺はいねえよ
たまにスペック不足で止まったりしたけど、ごめんね
何言ってんだ、お前はお前のスペックを最大限に生かして俺をサポートしてくれた
それだけで俺は充分だった
俺は忘れもしないぜ
お前と作った、たくさんの動画を
僕こそ最後まで使ってくれてア、リ、、ガ、、トウ
パタッ
ブク男おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお